[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
votre journal quotidien voici les titres
de cette édition du 12 janvier 2010 est
un chantier d'envergure va débuter à
saint quentin en yvelines à maurepas le
pont qui mène à la gare de la verrière
sera doublé bientôt la fin des
embouteillages aux heures de travail
politique et la gauche qui se prépare à
son premier débat ce jeudi les sept
prétendants vont échanger
l heure est à la préparation nous
reviendrons sur le mode d'emploi de ce
scrutin
et puis trouver à coup sûr la bonne
taille au cours de son shopping voici la
size machine un appareil que vous pouvez
tester dans plusieurs centres
commerciaux de la région alors que les
soldes viennent de débuter
le préfet des yvelines vient d'adresser
ses voeux aux personnalités et du
département c'est et hier soir à
versailles pas de discours pour cette
occasion mais des échanges plus discret
avec notamment les responsables des
différents corps de l'état remet
policiers ou encore pompiers parmi les
dossiers d'envergure du préfet serge
morvan pour 2010 est la bonne tenue des
élections présidentielle et législatives
mais aussi la gestion de l'accueil des
migrants ou encore l la mise en place
d'une aire d'accueil des gens du voyage
c'est un projet attendu par les
automobilistes saint quentinois depuis
longtemps les travaux du pont schuller
qui relie maurepas à la verrière vont
bientôt pouvoir débuter le pont va être
doublée avec elle des voies de bus créer
les travaux vont débuter dans quelques
jours quelques semaines ce sera tout
début février
ils vont durer tout de même deux ans le
point sur ces différents aménagements
c'est avec mélanie poker une situation
qui se répète chaque matin des voitures
au ralenti à la sortie de nos repas pour
rejoindre la gare de la verrière où la m
10 bientôt une ancienne histoire
le pont actuel qui est qui est derrière
nous va être
réhabiliter bien évidemment ce sera là
la dernière phase
il va être doublée sur la partie donc
sur la sur la gauche par à pau
métallique qui va être un pont sur le
plan en prs
un profil reconstituer soudé et ce sera
la partie qui sera affecté au tcsp le
transport en commun en site propre qui
permettra cette fluidité du trafic et
enfin au but d'arriver à l'heure de
façon tout à fait régulière
la pose du pont se fera elle de nuit
modifiant la circulation de la n10 sur
une voie entre février et septembre les
véhicules de particuliers conserveront
les deux voies actuelles de septembre à
fin avril 2002 18
donc ça va être les aménagements delà du
pont lui-même de façon à préparer le
basculement de la circulation sur
l'autre côté là ça va nous emmener pour
un bon moment il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
de travaux à faire de réfection de
chaussée les aménagements verront aussi
la création de pistes cyclables et une
voix vaulion directement le boulevard
guy schuller et la rue lui lormand d'un
coût de plus de 9 millions d'euros ces
travaux sont en partie financés par
l'état la région et le département
ils prendront fin en décembre 2018
politique à présent après les primaires
de la droite et du centre en novembre
dernier c'est au tour de celle de la
gauche et des écologistes ce jeudi soir
premier débat entre les sept prétendants
parmi eux benoît hamon depuis le début
du mois de décembre le député des
yvelines ne cesse de remonter dans les
sondages
deux de ces propositions devraient
alimenter les échanges dans quelques
heures le revenu universel ou encore la
légalisation du cannabis le scrutin va
lui se dérouler lors des deux dernier
dimanche de janvier et nous faisons le
point sur le fonctionnement le mode
d'emploi de ce scrutin ce soir c'est
avec mélanie poquet alors cette fois
aussi wilfrid c'est une élection ouverte
tout le monde peut voter mais à
certaines conditions alors pour les
scrutins des 22 et 29 janvier il faut
être de nationalité française être
inscrit sur les listes électorales avant
le 31 décembre 2016 il faudra aussi
signé une charte autour des valeurs de
la gauche de la gauche et des
écologistes et une participation de 1
euro sera demandée pour chaque tour
alors le jour j vous devrez bien sûr à
voir avec vous une pièce d'identité une
carte un passeport ou tout document
prouvant votre identité
si vous êtes inscrits au cours de
l'année
1016 sur les listes électorales il
faudra présenter un justificatif
d'inscription alors il faut savoir que
pourront aussi voter ceux qui seront
majeurs avant le 22 avril 2017 et les
adhérents mineurs de plus de 16 ans et
les adhérents étrangers des partis
organisateurs alors plus précisément
dans les yvelines 120 bureaux de vote
dans les showrooms ouvert de 9h à 19h et
plus de 700 militants et sympathisants
sont mobilisés plus précisément encore
cette fois sur saint quentin en yvelines
trois bureaux de vote seront ouverts par
exemple sur plaisir 4 à elancourt et 5 4
ap qui est la commune dans laquelle
benoît hamon a été conseiller municipal
jusqu'en janvier 2016 nord là je vous
écoute je vous propose d'écouter jean
claude husson
c'est le président de l'union des élus
socialistes et républicains des ivy
niveau explique le but de ce scrutin
c'est surtout de choisir un projet est
de choisir le candidat qui sera tout
soutenu par tous les partis qui
soutiennent ces équipements et il ya le
parti socialiste et le front démocrate
et à génération écologie
il ya l'union des démocrates et
écologistes et puis il ya le parti
radical de gauche donc tous ces partis
soutiendront le candidat qui sera choisi
à l'issue du deuxième tour alors pour
obtenir plus d'informations sur ces
primaires ou connaître tout simplement
le bureau de vote dans lequel vous
devrez vous rendre
direction le site
lesprimairescitoyennes.fr merci mélanie
et nous reviendrons justement sur ce
premier débat de la primaire ce sera ce
jeudi soir jeudi à 12 janvier nous y
reviendrons dans notre édition du 7 8
l'hebdo vendredi ce week end on parle de
soldes à présent et c'est une première
en france une saiz machine traduction en
français une machine pour calculer sa
taille elle a été installée dans
plusieurs centres commerciaux de parly 2
et vélizy 2 notamment pour ce premier
jour des soldes c'était hier le concept
est original a scanné le corps pour
permettre d'analyser la morphologie
exacte et connaître sa taille dans les
différentes enseignes
explication la plus grande hantise des
clients pendant les soldes c'est de ne
pas trouver la bonne taille grâce à la
side machines installées à vélizy 2
vous allez pouvoir connaître vos
mensurations exact l'intérêt c'est que
c'est d'une part une innovation c'est
quelque chose qui s'est jamais monté
dans les centres commerciaux du moins en
france
c'est en plus un service pour les
clients ce que ça permet de gagner du
temps en cabine donc on a directement sa
taille dans plusieurs magasins venant
ici
et puis et puis en plus c'est une
animation ça fait vivre le centre les
clients sont intéressés sont curieux et
viennent volontiers l'essayer donc
depuis ce matin ça ne désemplit pas une
caméra à l'intérieur de la salle des
machines calcul vous mensurations
quelques minutes plus tard vous avez
vous en faut en 3d avec votre taille
votre silhouette et les vêtements
adaptés à votre morphologie des
informations importantes qui séduisent
les premiers utilisateurs
déjà on a l'impression d'être dans un
truc futuriste le truc bouche tout seul
c'est assez marrant à faire et puis
c'est sympa puisque maintenant j'ai ma
taille dans toutes les boutiques delà de
la galerie donc je sais directement vers
comme diriger donc c'est plutôt sympa
ben c'était maman c'était marrant à
faire en fait le plateau bouge donc on a
au départ on s'y attend pas mais c'est
sympa vous pouvez utiliser la size
machines tous les week-ends durant les
soldes à vélizy 2 et parly 2 et nous
parlons toujours de nouvelles
technologies dans cette édition avec la
société infinity dream c'est une start
up de coignières qui propose à ses
clients de tester dans ses locaux est la
réalité virtuelle ou encore les
hologrammes plus d'une centaine de
personnes sont déjà passées dans cette
structure coup de projecteur avec mikel
ennemi de réalité virtuelle
hologram caméra 360 degrés la société
infinity dream est une entreprise touche
à tout ces start-up créée en septembre
dernier à coignières par six yvelinois
mordus de nouvelles technologies propose
à ses clients de tester ses produits
dernier cri
vous pouvez venir jouer à des jeux
voyager ou visionner des films voir des
scènes de théâtre des animaux n'y a
vraiment pas de limites c'est selon vos
envies on peut vous transporter
directement dans un monde virtuel
dans plusieurs univers différent pour
tester ces nouvelles technologies dans
ce temple de l'innovation de 60 m² un
groupe de quatre à six personnes devra
débourser 20 euros pour une heure la
structure organise également des
événements éphémères
on a essayé de faire quelques thèmes
quelques anniversaires
on a eu que des bons retours en
parallèle de son activité de réalité
virtuelle grégory bousseton et son
équipe ont importé du japon le concept
de la lévitation
cette innovation devrait leur permettre
de travailler avec des bijouteries des
boutiques de prêt-à-porter
donc on est obligé de s'adapter vraiment
pour être les meilleurs sur le marché
on a toujours de quoi surprendre même
les professionnels qui sont plus de
trente ans de métier on arrive à les
surprendre et enfin changera pas de la
société envisage déjà de développer un
deuxième centre à paris avant de se
tourner vers l'international dans les
prochaines années
après les traditions de noël ce sont
d'autres traditions qui reviennent au
mois de janvier et notamment celle du
ramassage des sapins des dizaines de
milliers de conifères sont broyés chaque
année juste dans les yvelines
tout au long du mois ce sont les
services techniques des communes qui
sont sollicités les entreprises
spécialisées également dans la collecte
qui doivent s'organiser pour les
recycler la magie des fêtes de noël
terminé les sapins se retrouvent
généralement sur le trottoir pour les
récupérer des employés de la société
plaisir aux assez pur spécialisée dans
le traitement des déchets sont mobilisés
ce mardi 10 janvier les agents six
lyonnais des rues des longs cours pour
réaliser au mieux sa tâche alexander
dominguez qui travaille depuis cinq ans
sur saint quentin en yvelines à ces
techniques et faire un peu d attention
parce que normalement que les sapins pas
normal qu ils étaient des cas d'arrêt
voler un bout du chemin il fait plus
attention mais les saints par quatre
fois pendant ce mois de janvier ils
encourent les agents vont devoir
batailler avec les épines pour retirer
les conifères de la voie publique
on connaît notre match donc ya pas de
base et ça a rien à changer
donc tout va bien à montigny le
bretonneux les sapins sont collectées
depuis le 2 janvier par la vie dans
dix-neuf enclos de dépôt une fois
récupérés par les agents municipaux les
conifères sont broyés dans les services
techniques de la commune
initiative a été lancée depuis 2013 je
crois en fait on les broie sur place ici
on a une benne qui régulièrement par
notre société de marché sur la
déchetterie nous emmène donc c'est
déchets verts sur l'autre la ville de
plaisir grignon il ya une déchetterie
une grande déchetterie sur place là bas
et en celui par la suite on peut
récupérer mais après on mélange une fois
composter ce type de matériau environ
2500 sapins seront broyés à montigny le
bretonneux pour récupérer entre 30 et 40
mètres cubes de compost l'opération
s'achèvera le lundi 23 janvier et
l'année prochaine il faudra recommencer
au mois de janvier prochain c'est la fin
de ce journal à leur rendez vous au
lundi aux horaires habituels pour une
toute nouvelle édition les reportages
sont à voir en replay dès à présent sur
notre site internet sur notre
application mobile également demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec
nicolas kirillovitch pour le 7 8
l'hebdo invité fil rouge de cette
édition du vendredi 13 janvier ce sera
michel laugier le président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
un an presque tout juste après
l'élargissement de 50 ans à 12 comme une
très bonne soirée
[Musique]